- On YouTube, there are several creators
with either a Big 4 background
or an MBB background
talking about their experiences,
but very rarely, you really
can see a conversation
where these two perspectives meet
and you can really understand and discuss
what the differences are
between Big 4 companies
and MBB companies.
This is exactly what this
video is going to be all about.
I partnered with KP, a
consultant at a Big 4 company,
and we both answered the same questions
about our experiences in consulting.
And I trust that the
comparison of these answers
will really help you to understand
what distinguishes MBB
firms from Big 4 firms.
Welcome everybody to another coffee break,
here on my channel, Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich and on my channel
I want to help you to be successful
in the first years of your career.
In this video and partnering with KP
from the @Management.Consultant Channel.
I can highly recommend her channel.
She has some super interesting
videos on consulting,
and I will leave a link to her channel
in the video description, so check it out.
But now instead of me talking
about KP, let's hear from her.
- Thanks Henry, my name is Kajol,
I am a strategy and innovation
consultant at Deloitte.
I help my clients to create
new products and services,
and I also do have a YouTube
channel on consulting,
helping you get into consulting,
once in, how do you stand out,
and also talking through
some of the biases
that we really do face in consulting.
Really excited for this video
and hopefully it can help you understand
if MBB or Big 4 is for you.
- And indeed this video
is one of two parts
so if you want to see
the second part as well
with other questions, for
both of our perspective
being answered checkout KP's channel
in the video description to see more.
But now without further ado,
let's jump into the questions.
- Big 4 is made up of
Deloitte, KPMG, EY and PwC.
And in 2019, they made up over 40%
of consulting revenue worldwide.
Typically they're much larger than MBB,
they're more global than MBB,
but they also offer
more services than MBB.
Over the past few years,
their consulting divisions
have really branched out
to buy smaller agencies, to
do a supply chain consulting,
innovation consulting, proposition design,
brand and marketing, and so on.
The other major difference is that MBB
definitely do charge their
clients a little bit more money,
and that means you're typically
going to get a higher salary
at MBB versus the Big 4.
- MBB refers to the leading
three strategy consulting firms,
McKinsey, BCG and Bain.
And strategy consulting
firms is a bit misleading
because these firms do
not only do strategy,
but probably the more
correct term to call them
would be top management consulting.
The vast majority of their business
is working together
with the top management
of large clients and trying to help them
solve the problems and issues
at the top of mind of the senior leaders
of the top management of these companies.
Most of these companies
do not officially disclose
their revenue figures, but
as per the Wikipedia page,
the latest estimate is that McKinsey
does roughly $10 billion in revenue,
BCG sits at around 8 billion
and Bain sits around 5 billion.
Regarding employees, McKinsey and BCG
are more or less on a similar
level at around 20,000,
Whereas Bain sits at about
10,000 employees globally.
My perspective of course will be biased
by my time at McKinsey
and of course there are also differences
among these three firms.
But overall, also from
talking to friends who worked
at these other companies, at BCG or Bain,
I do believe that they are
quite similar in many ways,
which is why you can consider my answers
indicatively right for
these other firms as well.
For me personally, it wasn't a big factor.
I did my undergrad in Munich,
at the university of Munich
and this is when I applied
to McKinsey for an internship
and while being a good
and renowned university
for business in Germany,
it's a large public university
with thousands of students
attending the business
program every semester.
But overall, yes, it is true
that McKinsey likes to hire
from the so called target schools,
from these elite universities.
I met lots and lots of people at McKinsey
who studied at an US Ivy league
or at Oxbridge or at the LSE
or at any other of these
very renowned universities.
So for sure this will
increase your chances
of getting into MBB.
And adding to that,
there might also be
differences in the offices,
how this is perceived.
For instance, in the US,
the differences among universities
are much more salient compared
to a country like Germany.
So you can likely expect that in the US,
the targets schools are more important,
more relevant than what
they are in Germany.
So overall, yes, it will help you,
but by no means this
is a hard requirement,
and you can get successfully into MBB
without studying at a target school.
- So I studied at Imperial College London,
and definitely the people
who joined with me,
they definitely came from a variety
of different universities.
Honestly, in the past, Big 4
definitely did used to recruit
from these elite schools
that Henry's mentioned
like Oxbridge, Ivy league and Imperial,
but diversity is a big
thing for Big 4 firms today
and they hire from a
variety of universities.
What they've realized is that
hiring from these universities
brings different viewpoints to
the table for their clients.
Everyone has different experiences,
different challenges
and struggles in life,
and they can go to a variety
of different universities.
Having a good uni can definitely help you
get screened, okay?
But it isn't everything.
So they look at education, experiences,
extracurricular activities,
achievements, and skills.
For anyone thinking that
education plays a massive part
in the recruitment process, I
would say, go onto LinkedIn,
have a look at where people
have studied at MBB and Big 4,
and you'll realize that
education isn't the end all.
- Yes. Up-or-Out exists.
And the underlying idea is that over time,
either you continue
advancing to the next role,
or at some point, if you fail to advance,
you will be asked to leave the firm.
Though it is not as
brutal as it maybe sounds.
The reason is that
there's a very transparent
feedback process at every point in time.
You know where you stand in the process
and in the evaluation.
If for any reason, your performance
would be started to seen as problematic,
there will be many iterations of feedback
that people will give you,
people will actively reach out to you
to work together with you
to work on your weak points,
to make sure that you meet the bar,
that you meet the requirements
for the next level,
to really help you as much as possible
to be successful in the firm.
That being said, at every
level, there will be people
who will be asked to leave the firm.
If you start at an MBB company,
you just need to be aware
that these are the rules
of the game, that this is how it works.
This being said, if this is
something that happens to you,
HR professionals will
work together with you
to find you a new job.
Of course, MBB firms have a vast network
and will work together with
you to help you identify
new job opportunities
that suit your needs.
- Yes, in many countries,
Big 4 definitely does have
an Up-and-Out process, but in the UK,
it's actually very difficult to get fired
for poor performance.
We have this Acas code of practice by law.
It basically says that you
have to consistently show
you're a bad performer
for a firm to fire you.
They also need to support you,
so they need to give you a few chances
and also put you on a supporting plan
to show that they've tried
to improve your performance.
So the Big 4 does have very
transparent feedback processes,
happens once every quarter
where leadership get together
to speak about you, to
understand who needs support,
and identify how everyone's doing.
That means there's also a very
structured promotion process.
So once every year in the junior levels,
you can go for promotion,
even early promotion,
and you have a defined set of guidelines
that you need to meet every
grade for you to get promoted.
So it's really clear if you
want to go for promotion,
you know exactly what you need to do.
- Regarding the project set up,
what probably distinguishes
most MBB projects
from Big 4 projects is the team size
and the type of topics that
the consultants will work on.
It is no secret that MBB
fees are rather expensive.
And for sure, more expensive
than your average Big 4 firm.
For these reasons, MBB
teams are rather small
and rather work on the most important,
most pressing challenges
that the company is facing.
A typical MBB team size ranges
from two to four consultants,
including the project lead,
and then one or two
partners joining the team
once or twice a week,
and then adding their value
and their perspective as well.
This means that from early
on, you are one of two,
one of three or one of four consultants.
And of course by that,
you are a significant part of the team.
The responsibility that
you will get early on
from your very first
project will be significant.
Due to the importance of the topics
that MBB firms work with,
you will work together with
rather senior executives,
often even with board members,
and will learn to develop
documents for this audience
and present in front of them as well.
This being said, MBB
firms in the last years,
tried to expand the
diversity of the projects
in other directions as well,
which is why today you can
find projects in an MBB firm
that now more closely resemble projects
that you would also find in Big 4.
Specifically, most MBB firms today
also have different variations
of implementation type
of inciting services.
This means that you do not
only work on super strategic,
super conceptual projects,
but you also might find
yourself in a position
to really work on projects
that are much closer
to implementation setting
that are really about execution
and bringing ideas to life.
Often ideas that then
prior teams before you
develop with the client.
So from this perspective
there for sure is an overlap
regarding the types of projects
and the team set up between MBB and Big 4.
Though still, the typical MBB project
will be different than
the typical Big 4 project.
- Just like Henry's mentioned,
MBB have definitely branched
out to the implementation work
but Big 4 definitely rule king
when it comes to breadth of services.
We acquired some really cool companies
to strengthen our practices from strategy,
technology, operations,
supply chain, human capital,
as well as brand,
marketing and innovation.
If you're working on a
strategy or prime project,
you typically do work in
small teams of two to four.
You'll end up having a partner
who looks after the
relationship with the client,
a manager, and maybe an analyst
or consultant on that team.
On operations or technology projects,
they can be really
small, from two to four,
but they can be massive to 300.
So you need to have a variety
of leadership on there
and work in smaller structures
whereas still ensuring there's a big team.
So typically they end
up being in work streams
and you have smaller teams within it,
but those small teams end
up being from four to 15
to even 20 sometimes.
- Thank you for watching.
I really hope that you took
some value out of this video.
If you have any more questions,
just leave me a comment
below in the comment section
and I will do my very best
to answer every single one.
Please, if you took any
value out of this video,
please destroy the like button
for the YouTube algorithm,
and also subscribe to my
channel to see even more content
like this. If you want
to see even more from me,
hit me up on my Instagram.
My Instagram handle is @FirmLearning
and I also have a mailing
list with even more content.
You can find a sign up link to that
in the video description.
Thank you for watching.
I really appreciate your time.
I wish you the very best,
have a good evening,
all the best to you and
see you next Saturday.